Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is 2192. David P Here is a very good question
about what happens if Trump is the nominee
and loses in 24. Take a listen to this. It's
something I've been thinking about for sure.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, should we be worried
about what Trump supporters are
going to do if Trump loses in 2024?
Speaker 1: I believe we should be worried. The
question really that's being asked is will MAGA
riot again if Trump loses in 2024? I hope the
answer is no. I pray the answer is no. I don't
even pray. But this I might pray for. I really
hope that they are not going to riot if he loses.
I do think it makes sense for law enforcement to
be more prepared. Maybe. But honestly, everything
surrounding Trump lately has been so low energy.
I mean, you know, with the arrest, there were
going to be big protests. There was a protest with
like 40 people and a couple hundred members of the
media and police. Not a big showing. Let's hope
that MAGA remains as deflated as they've been and
that no matter what outcome there is, there is no
violence. We're thinking very far ahead and we're
going to wait and see. On the bonus show today.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Number one will be making
money on the bonus show. Number two,
the Supreme Court is preserving access to the
abortion pill for now. And for now is a big thing.
We will talk about the continued expansion of AI,
including songs written and performed by a I Are
You and I NPC listening to a music and you don't
even know it. What would that do to you? Okay,
we'll talk about that. And we will also talk about
new polling. This this is kind of just depressing.
Majorities don't want Biden nor Trump to
run in 2024 based on new polling. What is
it mean? All of those stories and more
on the bonus show, which you can sign
up for at joint Patterson dot com. I'll see
everybody then or right back here tomorrow.